the newly born Universe buzzed and Frost
with Boundless Energy even after the
Raging furnace of the first few minutes
had died away temperatures Universe wide
were more than a hundred million degrees
for thousands of years this Primal heat
burned Cosmos of plasma a super hot mix
of particles and radiation
until one day it changed forever
that day arrived when the universe was
almost 400 000 years old and had cooled
to about 3 000 Kelvin in this now
comparatively tepid soup lone electrons
methylone protons and finally could
stick together forming the first atoms
but this was not all for each electron
and proton bound together a small amount
of energy was released a packet of
energy that raced away the cosmic speed
limit the speed of light a particle of
energy born in the formation of a
hydrogen atom a particle we call a
photon a particle of light itself
this Photon was far from the first but
as the universe began transitioning from
plasma into neutral gas light could then
for the first time stream freely through
its reaches and so how photons long long
journey
began
it headed out first into the universe's
Dark Ages a time before the first Stars
burned a time before the first galaxies
formed in the Eerie Darkness gravity
pulled on mass to mold the first seeds
of cosmic structure
the photon sped on and noticed nothing
eventually the first Stars burst into
life around it massive and Bloated these
ancient Suns burned themselves out in a
cosmic blink of an eye as the first
supergiant black holes grew rapidly
between them as they eagerly devoured
Mass
but the photon sped on
and notice nothing
the first galaxies began to assemble the
sky lit up with the fires of uncountable
young Stars across the cosmos as they
began to fuse the initial hydrogen and
helium atoms into heavier elements
but the photon sped on
and noticed
nothing
Millions steadily turned into billions
of years and as galaxies grew and
matured eventually the intense light of
young Stars began to settle the photon's
journey could have potentially lasted
forever into eternity but after almost
14 billion light years of travel a large
spiral galaxy steadily came into view
its Destiny was set
near a small blue dot orbiting a small
white star after crossing the last few
thousand light years the photon collided
with a piece of metal part of a
telescope built by humans and orbiting
near the planet Earth
the photon's energy was completely
absorbed energizing electrons and
registering on detectors
but as the photon vanished from
existence its billions year-long Journey
complete
it's still simply did not notice
because to the photon itself
the journey never took place
13.8 billion years of cosmic time
disappeared in an instant
yet how can this be light has existed in
the universe from its earliest moments
and will continue to exist long after
humanity and the stars are shred to dust
just how does it work and how can it
seemingly last forever
perhaps most importantly
what even is it
light is fast it only takes 0.13 seconds
for it to circulate the entire Globe
through fiber optic cables that slows
down by a third but that still means
that with surf shark changing your
virtual location is almost instantaneous
so if shark have been kind enough to
sponsor this video and they are the best
simplest VPN service out there you can
change your country quickly and easily
to stream whatever you want from
wherever you want in the world with more
than 100 countries to choose from veit
seems to escape definition as it
exhibits properties of both the particle
and a wave and now you too can be
similarly inscrutable to Big tech
companies and cyber criminals by using
surf shark to mask your IP address and
encrypting your data on public Wi-Fi
it's the best way to secure your
personal information when using the
internet and even warns you of potential
data breaches so check out surfshark by
clicking on the link in the description
and get 83 off and three months for free
as well as a 30-day money-back guarantee
thanks to surf shark for supporting
educational content on YouTube
[Music]
light had played a pivotal role since
the cosmos's very beginning in these
earlier times it had only existed for
the very briefest of moments slamming
into speeding particles before it had a
chance to travel anywhere one piece of
light dying as another was born however
our parcel of light was born into a very
different very transparent Universe with
the cosmic Maelstrom of the Big Bang
finally abated our Photon could begin
its immense Journey unhindered as it
traveled many generations of stars led
to our sun and billions of years after
humans began to walk on the surface of
our small rocky planet and So eventually
as our Photon was a couple of thousand
light years distant from Earth
those humans began
to wander
all men by Nature desire to know an
indication of this is the Delight we
take in our senses and above all others
the sense of sight this most of all the
senses makes us know and brings to light
many differences between things
the ancient Greeks wondered if light
emanated from the eyes touching and
feeling the world around us but clearly
there are times when it is dark when we
can't see anything so they concluded
light must be something external
something captured by our eyes Islamic
scientists went on to unravel the
properties of light finding rules of
reflection and the magnification
properties of glass lenses light was
clearly a natural part of the universe
around us
but it took the coming of the Scientific
Revolution and a fight between two
giants of science the light's deepest
secrets to be finally uncovered
the year was 1652 and Dutch physicist
astronomer mathematician and all-round
genius Christian Huygens was exploring
Optical phenomena he had noted how light
traveled through lenses and bounced off
mirrored surfaces and was particularly
interested in the phenomenon of
refraction where the path of light is
bent when it passes from one medium to
another
Huygens noticed that light was often
split into the colors of the rainbow by
his instruments and sometimes strange
patterns of dark and light would be
produced clear evidence to him that
light was some sort of wave some sort of
traveling oscillating phenomenon
oscillations can be found throughout
nature from planetary orbits to
vibrating electrons but let's start with
a simple picture
think of a child on a swing
as they swing their position oscillates
from one position to the next and then
back again just like a pendulum that
drives the regular ticking and talking
of a grandfather clock when oscillations
act in unison but slightly out of Step
waves are formed a stone thrown in a
flat Pond pulls the water down with it
but the water bounces back this splash
of water pulls on its neighbors inducing
them to oscillate which in turn pulls on
their own neighbors these oscillations
fan out across the pond as a steadily
Rippling pattern of waves waves are
everywhere from sound waves Crossing in
the air to ocean water waves driven by
the wind and moon seismic shifts can
generate violent and destructive
earthquakes in our planetary crust
whilst similar waves Ripple in the
atmosphere of the Sun and other stars
and so light seemed also to be a wave
but this left an obvious question if
light is a wave
just what was doing the waving
in Britain Robert Hook also reached a
similar conclusion about the nature of
light and he realized that this picture
of wavy light could explain a lot of the
phenomenon he had seen this was
cutting-edge science at the time but
hook had a problem
and that problem
was a man
there are no surviving portraits of
Robert Hook and over the years a rumor
passed down the generations that this
powerful man was to blame having
conveniently lost the painting when
taking over his head of the Royal
Society in London for Robert Hook had a
powerful enemy and that enemy's name
was Isaac Newton
since cleared of any wrongdoing in the
absence of contemporary images of hook
there is still little question that the
two men were not friends for as well as
his far-reaching discoveries in
mathematics and gravity Newton also had
an interest in Optics and the nature of
light itself and he did not like what
hook or highgens had to say indeed it
was Newton who discovered that white
light could be split into a rainbow by
passing it through a prism and like hook
he had kept musing on this but unlike
hook Newton did not conclude that light
was some sort of wave to Newton light
consisted of corpuscles to Newton light
was made of tiny individual
particles
[Music]
Newton's Focus was the phenomenon of
diffraction the fact that waves bend
around a sharp edge he knew the sound a
wave in the air bent as it traveled past
sharp edges it was clear that you could
eavesdrop on a conversation from around
a corner without being able to see the
gossipers you could hear from behind an
object but you could not see so he
reasoned light simply could not be a
wave
and he didn't stop there Newton went
further much much further he reasoned
the light as a stream of particles would
even feel the pull of gravity in his
book Optics published in 1704 he wrote
do not bodies act upon light at a
distance and by their action Bend its
rays and though on this he was correct
he was not proved correct for centuries
so it was Newton's corpuscular theory of
light that reigned Supreme due more to
his weight of personality and scientific
standing as opposed to its ability to
explain the complex observations of
light
over the years however steadily the tide
began to turn away from Newton
in 1800 polymath Thomas Young Shawn
light threw a pair of narrow slits and
observed a pattern of interference on a
background screen this wasn't the first
demonstration of interference but it was
the clearest how could Newton's picture
of light as particles explain Young's
observation of interference how could
light as Tiny bullets passing through
either one slit or the other produce The
observed pattern simply throwing a
couple of Pebbles into a Still Pond
reveals that interference is naturally
produced by waves either in water or in
light other observations of light
supported its wave-like nature including
light's polarization through a material
called calcite but for centuries the big
secondary question remained unanswered
if light was a wave
just what was doing
the waving
foreign
[Music]
parcel of light was born when a proton
captured an electron It sped out into
the universe powerful and energetic but
as it traveled and the universe expanded
it started to lose some of that energy
the light originally blew to our eyes
steadily morphed through the colors of
the rainbow and into the red soon it was
joined by other energetic light shining
from countless billions of newly formed
stars there were different types of
light as well light of exceptionally
high energy and light with barely any
energy at all
the universe was Awash
of course our light did not know that
these would be invisible to human eyes
for it would be many billions of years
until eyes existed and indeed these
X-rays and radio waves as we call them
were unknown to us until the very end of
the 19th century
[Music]
in this new era thought itself will be
transmitted by radio
gulielmo Marconi was at his father's
estate near bologna in Italy he was
still a young man aged only 20 but his
education had opened his eyes to an
invisible world in the decades before
the nature of light had steadily been
unraveled and Marconi was ready to use
this newfound knowledge to change
everything staring at his equipment
Marconi was waiting to see a faint spark
in the darkness with the bundle of wires
and coils of his Workshop such a spark
could not be surprising but the impetus
for this spark was not in the equipment
before him it was in similar equipment
located several miles away of course the
19th century had seen the arrival of the
telegraph where electronic pulses were
sent along wires that crossed entire
countries and continents but this needed
wires to be strung through the air and
under the oceans Marconi had no need for
such wires he would be sending messages
not along bits of copper his messages
would simply fly completely unseen
through the air
but how
the answer lies with one of science's
greatest Geniuses the answer lies with
James Clark Maxwell
[Music]
when a young James Clark Maxwell arrived
at the University of Cambridge in 1850
he was told that attendance at the 6 a.m
church service was compulsory for all
students
The scottish-born Prodigy had long been
a night owl and simply responded I I
suppose I could stay up that late his
name is writ large across the modern
world with his crowning achievement was
uniting two seemingly disparate
phenomena and creating something
remarkable
electricity and magnetism had been known
about since ancient times seen in the
strange attraction of robbed materials
and mysterious stones that knew how to
find North but by the 19th century it
was becoming clear that these two were
not truly distinct a flow of an electric
current could generate a magnetic field
and a changing magnetic field could
generate a current in a wire but as
Maxwell stared at these equations he
began to see a deeper picture instead of
separate relationships he saw that
electricity and magnetism could be
united into a single hole a United set
of mathematics that encompassed all
electric and all magnetic phenomena
but Maxwell's great Insight was not only
concerned with electromagnetic
complexity for he wondered about the
simplest situation of all
electromagnetism in the nothingness of a
vacuum
how does light travel through the
emptiness of space
Maxwell knew that electromagnetic fields
filled all of space even in vacuums but
it was imagined that in empty space
these fields would be null effectively
not there but what if you plucked one of
these fields either electric or magnetic
so that these fields were not at zero at
some location Maxwell pondered this
question using his equations to explore
how the situation would evolve and the
answer was astounding think about
pinching the skin on the back of your
hand what happens when you let go of
your pinch your skin sinks back to its
unpinched self quickly if you are young
and somewhat slower if you are older
Maxwell's equations told him that the
electromagnetic pinch would evolve away
back to zero but that this was not the
end of the story pinching the electric
field would generate a similar pinch in
the magnetic field and the pinch in the
magnetic field would generate a pinch in
the electric field and these pinches did
not simply fade back to zero instead
they oscillated regenerating each other
from one moment to the next and just
like ripples on a pond these
oscillations traveled away as waves
and so Maxwell realized these
oscillations had the property of a light
light he realized is a self-propagating
electromagnetic wave but what was
causing the ripples what was the
electromagnetic equivalent of the stone
thrown in the pond he saw that it was
electric charges something we now know
as electrons as these charges jiggle and
oscillate they disturb nearby electric
and magnetic fields and these
disturbances Ripple away as
electromagnetic radiation what we call
light he also realized that the inverse
must be true as light entered the eye
and fell on the retina the oscillations
of the light must cause electrons in
atoms in the eye to jiggle and it is
this jiggling of electrons in the eye
center signals to the brain that we
perceive as vision
[Music]
finally Maxwell understood what it was
that was waving and what caused the
waves
and one more thing
he knew that light had waves with a
length of about a millionth of a meter
but his equations showed no limitation
on the wavelength of his electromagnetic
waves and so he concluded that there
must be light with both long and short
wavelengths that is invisible to the eye
it would take two more decades for the
answer to this puzzle to present itself
decades in which Maxwell died of cancer
at the age of only 48.
in 1886 Heinrich Hertz working at the
University of karlsruhe was the first to
find these invisible waves
named herzian waves after their
Discoverer a new Revolution had been
born we now refer to these herzian waves
as radio Hertz was understandably very
pleased with his Discovery but when
asked about the Practical use these
radio waves have he apparently responded
nothing I guess
and yet it was these radio waves that
only a few years later Marconi was using
to send messages across miles and then
across counties oceans and all across
the immensity of the globe
[Music]
in 1909 Marconi received the Nobel Prize
for his work on wireless telegraphy
Hertz however died in 1894 at the
youthful age of 36 never seeing the true
promise of his discovery
the world was set to become full of
invisible light as the 20th century
began and the Mystery of light's
properties seemed settled
that was until 1905.
and a remarkable year for one German
patent Clerk
[Music]
the universe continued to change and
evolve as our particle of light traveled
the mixture of light joining it on its
Journey reflected that change bursts of
radio waves and high energy gamma rays
becoming more and more frequent this
energy surged through space much of it
flowing between the stars and into the
darkness but some encountered lone atoms
in The Emptiness of the Void the low
energy radio waves very gently Shook and
energized these atoms like a calm ocean
wave lapping at a Sandy Shore just as we
would expect from Maxwell's picture of
electromagnetic waves but the behavior
of the high energy gamma rays was
different they delivered their energy to
the atoms with a violent punch that
ripped electrons clean away not a
lapping Ripple but an isolated smash
the gamma rays hit the atoms not like
waves but like hard little energetic
particles
but how could Maxwell be wrong could on
some occasions light be more like
Newton's vision and act like a particle
and if so just what would those
occasions be
[Music]
for the present we have to work on both
theories on Mondays Wednesdays and
Fridays we use the wave theory on
Tuesdays Thursdays and Saturdays we
think in streams of flying energy quanta
or corpuscles
[Music]
Alfred Nobel had made his fortune
through his inventions and his
businesses especially in the field of
explosives and weapons and so perhaps
not unfairly in an 1888 obituary in a
French newspaper he was called The
Merchant of death
this surprised Nobel firstly as he was
still very much alive but secondly and
more distressingly because he realized
what his historical Legacy was to be so
in his will he decided to leave most of
his fortune to a series of prizes prizes
that would honor those that have
conferred the greatest benefit to
humankind across science the Nobel
prizes are perhaps the most prestigious
the list of winners replete with the
Giants of science over more than a
century and in 1901 the inaugural Nobel
Prize in physics was awarded to the
German Wilhelm rundgan for his
discoveries about the nature of light
for it was he who discovered the X-ray
ronkin's experiments with various
materials found that only the densest
could halt x-rays he even managed to
convince his wife Bertha to place her
hand in the beam after realizing his
x-rays should stream through her flesh
but be partly blocked by her denser
bones thus producing the first x-ray
photograph
whilst it was suspected that X-rays were
electromagnetic radiation with a
wavelength much smaller than visible
light as opposed to radar which was much
longer it took several decades to
conclusively show that this was the case
although in the meantime the medical
application of x-rays to fix bones and
save lives grew without bounds
and so this meant that by the early
1900s Maxwell's vision of
electromagnetic waves beyond the visible
had been undoubtedly confirmed all of
light's Secrets uncovered even the
electron having been discovered all the
remained was to find the rest of the
light we could not see gamma rays
microwaves and more to fill out the last
gaps on the electromagnetic spectrum and
wrap up the story
[Music]
but of course if physics feels that a
job is done a rude shock is usually just
around the corner
in Maxwell's picture of light it could
be thought of as a continuous wave
scientists had found that when light
crashed into most materials it
continuously dumped energy that
energized electrons causing them to be
emitted this was called the
photoelectric effect by lowering the
intensity of light it took longer for
energy to be deposited and it usually
took longer for the electrons to begin
to be spat out
usually for that was not what was
observed when light was shown on certain
Metals electrons would seemingly be
ejected instantaneously from the metal
surface and the really confusing
observation came from adjusting the
color of the light being shown blue
light would result in very energetic
electrons being emitted green light
resulted in less energetic electrons and
red light produced no electrons at all
this made no sense if all colors of
light carry energy why did Red Light
fail to energize the electrons
this mystery was solved and new
Mysteries were born in a very special
year this was no ordinary year it was a
miraculous year for it was the year that
Albert Einstein changed physics
forever
most people are familiar with Einstein's
Anna's mirabilis 1905 the year he wrote
down the special theory of relativity
but that was just the beginning Einstein
was awarded the Nobel Prize in physics
in 1921. the citation noted the award
was for his services to theoretical
physics yet one Topic in particular was
singled out for recognition and it was
not his work on relativity it was
especially for his discovery of the law
of the photoelectric effect
when Einstein explored the photoelectric
effect he had to radically revise
Maxwell's vision of light he realized
that when light interacted with
electrons it could not do so as a
continuous wave of energy instead the
energy must be concentrated and dumped
into an electron as an instantaneous
packet light Einstein declared must be
quantized it must be chunks of energy it
must interact
like a particle
Einstein went on to explain that each
packet of energy was proportional to the
frequency of the light a packet of red
light carries less energy than a packet
of green light a packet of green light
carries less energy than a packet of
blue and so in experiments the red light
simply didn't deliver enough energy for
an electron to escape
[Music]
this enigmatic packet of energy didn't
get its current name until 1926 when in
an article in the journal Nature Gilbert
Lewis coined the name Photon evidence
for the particle nature of light swiftly
grew and it was in 1923 Arthur Compton
put together an important experiment but
one that relied on a bizarre fact
light
can push
this might seem like a strange thing to
say how can light which has no Mass push
but Maxwell's equations showed that in
carrying energy light also carries
momentum you can easily buy a Crooks
radiometer today as an executive toy for
your desk consisting of four veins in an
evacuated glass tube one side black and
the other side white when placed in
bright sunlight the veins begin to spin
pushed supposedly by the momentum of
nothing more than sunlight as ever the
physics of the Crux radiometer is more
complex than this simple explanation but
the force of sunlight pushing on the
veins is real with some Visionaries
imagining future Humanity coursing
amongst the planet's solar sailing on
sunlight
in 1923 Arthur Compton's experiment
however was a little different in his
experiment Compton aimed a beam of high
energy X-rays at an atomic Target thus
ripping electrons from the outer part of
the atoms but when examining the
rebounding X-rays and recoiling
electrons Compton found that Maxwell's
picture of a wave of energy and momentum
simply did not work instead Compton had
to treat the x-rays and electrons like
colliding billiard balls for when an
x-ray hit an electron it delivered its
energy and its momentum as a discrete
packet when an x-ray hit an electron
they definitively interacted
like hard particles
Newton's vision of particles of light
was reborn but was this definitive proof
that light was a particle
not quite there was of course still a
mountain of evidence for its wave-like
nature if anything scientists were more
confused than ever before despite
Maxwell's picture of electromagnetic
waves proving extremely powerful and
successful these experiments in the
early 1900s demanded that light must be
a particle and so people began to wander
was there even an answer to be found
we began this story following a photon
of light as it traveled across the
universe Maxwell tells us that this
Photon was formed by the changing energy
of an electron and that it vanishes when
finally absorbed by electrons at its
Journey's End
but what happens in between is this Epic
Journey simply governed by Fate does the
photon really fly off in a random
Direction careening into an electron at
some arbitrary point in its future this
question is the next part of our story
from the early 20th century it was
realized that this simply could not be
the case
in the language of quantum mechanics the
photons Journey has nothing to do with
chance
not only is the universe Stranger than
we think it is Stranger than we can
think
we begin on a chilly morning in France
in January 1793.
with a swish of a guillotine Blade the
King Louis XVI was no more throughout
this upheaval chaos reigned across
France Victor Francois the second Duke
de broy battled for his King but
eventually like many others of the
aristocracy he fled France for safety
abroad the de bruise eventually returned
to their native France to shape the
country after the upheaval of Revolution
and after a series of Statesmen
diplomats and writers in 1892 into the
de bruy family was born the man who
would change our understanding of
everything
his name was Louis Victor Pierre Ramon
seventh Duke dubroy but in the annals of
physics history he is simply known as
the broy
in the early 20th century he bore
witness to the birth of quantum
mechanics and the growing confusion
about whether light was a particle or a
wave to Deborah however there was one
obvious solution though a
counter-intuitive one light was neither
and both at the same time it was clear
that light when it traveled traveled as
a wave producing the effects of
interference and diffraction but when it
interacted it interacted like a particle
it seemed to exhibit properties of being
both a particle and a wave but was never
really either de broyer's remarkable
Insight was to realize that this was
true not only for light but for the
entire Quantum world
here he claimed there were no true
particles and no true waves everything
de broyer told us was some sort of
quantum
thing
and so in his PhD in 1924 he claimed
that electrons which were clearly
particles should also exhibit wave-like
properties and in 1929 he received the
Nobel Prize when experiments or out his
predictions there has been significant
philosophical discussion about this wave
particle duality in quantum mechanics
but its observational consequences are
incontrovertible a series of single
photons or electrons sent through
multiple slits still result in
interference patterns and even large
complex molecules have also been shown
to have properties of both waves and
particles the largest yet tested being 2
000 atoms in size and so with quantum
mechanics in hand the quest was on to
understand just how light and electrons
interacted
with classical physics the physics of
Maxwell electrons jiggled as
electromagnetic waves passed by just
like seagulls bobbing on a choppy ocean
and by their jiggling the electrons
emitted their own electromagnetic waves
adding to the mix but the quantum
picture had to be different for the
quantum world was one of quanta and
particle reactions
despite these opposing situations it
didn't take long for a solution to be
found and it was another scientific
Titan Paul Adrian Maurice Dirac that
began to crack the code in the late
1920s he was working to unite two of the
greatest breakthroughs in modern physics
The Strange World of quantum mechanics
and Einstein's special theory of
relativity dirac's story has been told
many times about his famous
absent-mindedness and lack of
communication skills Quantum Pioneer
Niels Bohr went as far as to call him
the strangest man but there was
absolutely no doubt that Iraq was a
revolutionary genius and it was through
his work on quantum mechanics the Dirac
made his mark on scientific history
to understand the modern view he helped
to bring about we have to accept that
everything is actually
feels
these fields are different to things
like classical electric and magnetic
fields in Quantum field Theory there are
electron Fields Photon Fields fields for
the various quarks and more a ripple for
example in the electron field is an
electron and a ripple in the photon
field a photon
think of an atom what do you see in our
minds we often have the picture given to
us by Niels Bohr of electrons orbiting a
nucleus like a planet orbiting a star
and when an electron jumps from a higher
orbit to a lower orbit a photon of light
is emitted but when considering the
quantum world this is not quite correct
in Quantum field Theory we think of an
orbiting electron as a vibrational
pattern in the electron field the higher
energy orbit is one particular pattern
and the lower energy orbit is another
in the language of physics the electron
field and the photon field are coupled
together and jumping between the higher
and lower orbits the electron field
generates a vibration in the photon
field
Quantum field theory has grown to become
arguably the most successful theory of
our world to date describing almost
everything in our universe across 24
Quantum Fields corresponding to the
various possible interactions of the
standard model and so simple everything
is fields and the fields interact
but of course as they often do in the
quantum World things are about to get a
lot stranger many of the greatest minds
of quantum mechanics were involved in
this move towards strangeness but
perhaps the most well-known is a man
from Far Rockaway with a broad Brooklyn
accent
a man named Richard Feynman
born in 1918 he started his career as
part of the Manhattan Project and was
recommended by Oppenheimer himself for
Berkeley in a now famous letter sent in
1942 he is by all Lords the most
brilliant young physicist here and
everyone knows this I may give you two
quotations from men with whom he has
worked beta has said that he would
rather lose any two other men than
Feynman from this present job and vigna
said he is a second Iraq only this time
human though his 1985 autobiography
surely you're joking Mr Feynman was an
eye-opener for many not only regarding
his numerous contributions to science
but also his extroverted personality and
complex private life including a ponchon
for strip clubs these aspects did not
fit the stereotypical vision of a
professor indeed Murray girl man another
giant of quantum mechanics once even
quipped of Feynman feinman was a great
scientist but he spent a great deal of
his effort generating anecdotes about
himself
And yet when it came to thinking about
the quantum world for many physicists
Feynman changed everything
[Music]
whilst feynman's famous quip that no one
truly understands quantum mechanics may
have been true Feynman himself certainly
understood the depth of the mathematics
that underlies it
this gave him the insights to think
about the true nature of light and how
it interacts
it all starts with a solitary electron
in the electromagnetics of Maxwell the
charge of the electron results in an
electric field surrounding it and a
charge in an electric field feels the
presence of the electric field in this
situation there must be energy in the
interaction but the question was how
much the problem was every time Feynman
tried to calculate the amount of energy
the answer came out to be the same
Infinity so Feynman did something quite
radical he threw away the classical
notion of the electric field as defined
by Maxwell in the acceptance speech for
the award of his Nobel Prize in 1965
Feynman said I suggested to myself that
electrons cannot act on themselves they
can only act on other electrons
and a new bizarre picture of the
interaction of light and electrons
emerged
[Music]
the best visual representation of this
interaction is the diagram named after
Feynman himself
the Feynman diagram
they are often a complicated mixture of
lines Wiggles and Loops but at their
heart Feynman diagrams describe all of
the possible interactions in quantum
mechanics to pick apart a Feynman
diagram it is best to start with the
simplest of interactions the interaction
between electrons and Light
Feynman diagrams represent an
interaction over space and time lone
electrons Trace out straight line paths
through space-time a path known as its
World line the electron is really just a
vibration in the quantum electron field
and with no interactions it happily
traces a simple straight line path we
also know however that the electron
field can couple with the photon field
and when this happens the vibrations in
the electron field change in an atom the
electron jumps from a high energy orbit
to a low energy orbit but for a free
electron conservation of momentum means
that the electron changes direction if
we imagine this over space time the
world line of the electron possesses a
distinct Kink and this occurs where and
when the photon usually depicted as a
wavy line is emitted this structure this
Junction is known as a vertex and it is
the basic Lego piece
for building all Feynman diagrams of
course full Feynman diagrams are more
complex than a single vertex they
usually combine several distinct pieces
the emitted Photon from one electron is
eventually received by another electron
two vertices are joined together to give
the complete interaction two kinked
electron paths joined with the wiggly
line representing the photon but what
governs the coupling between the
electron field and the photon field this
is related to the charge on the electron
and one of Nature's constants the fine
structure constant this is
electromagnetism and the exchange of the
photon between two electrons is the
electromagnetic force in action
and so in feynman's view we wave goodbye
to the electromagnetic field in its
place we simply have two electrons
interacting through the exchange of a
photon and when huge numbers of these
photons are exchanged it approximates
the classical Force even though at its
heart this electromagnetic force is a
Quantum phenomenon
[Music]
and it's not just electromagnetism for
it is also true for the fundamental weak
and strong nuclear forces
for the strong force it is gluons
instead of photons that are exchanged
between quarks and for the weak force it
is via the exchange of massive particles
known as the w and z and again all of
these forces can be presented by a
combination of Feynman vertices
but this was not the end Feynman had one
even stranger card yet to play when it
came
to light
he had said that one electron acts upon
another and this happens through the
exchange of a photon producing the
complete Feynman diagram of the
interaction but did this mean that an
electron fired out a photon at random
did this Photon stream out into the
universe with only a remote chance of
being absorbed by another electron
counter-intuitively the answer Feynman
said was no he told us that the photon
is only passed between two electrons
that have agreed on the exchange
but there is something odd happening
here if we are in the middle of the
photon's journey it's emission from one
electron occurred in the past while the
absorption of the photon by the other
electron is going to occur in the future
so when did the electrons communicate
and agree to exchange the photon how did
they even know of each other's presence
it clearly cannot be via the
electromagnetic force as this is
precisely what the exchange of the
photon actually is
so what is the solution
as with a lot of quantum mechanics
what's the mathematics just works the
interpretation the question of what is
really happening is the biggest
challenge and so Feynman with his
supervisor John Wheeler put a
mind-bending possibility on the table
[Music]
the suggestion is something we now call
the transactional interpretation they
said that the two electrons handshake
their acceptance of exchanging the
photon but that this handshake is taken
Through Time one electron messages from
the past
and the other
from the future this might sound
ridiculous but it completely fits with
the mathematics of quantum mechanics
and so on a dark night when you gaze at
a distant star an electron in your eye
and an electron in the atmosphere of
that star spoke to each other through
time and agreed to exchange the photon
you see
and going even further for the lonely
Photon we met at the beginning of our
story two distant electrons shook hands
over billions of years of time billions
of light years of space and agreed that
the photon should undertake it Cosmic
Journey
the bizarre world of quantum mechanics
never disappoints
and yet there is one final even stranger
mystery to unfold about light and our
lonely Photon in the Blackness of space
as it travels over many billions of
light years
just what does the photon
experience
we've followed our Photon over many
billions of years eventually a Journey's
End the universe it inhabits is very
different to the one of its birth
yet there is a disconnect for once this
Photon was almost as old as the universe
itself
it remained
eternally useful
galaxies formed in the void stars were
born lived and died whole superclusters
splintered and collapsed
and the photon Misty doll because to the
photon time itself
meant nothing
this might seem like a strange thing to
say the photon clearly had an existence
in time but with the coming of Einstein
and his special theory of relativity it
was realized that time was actually
flexible it was relative dependent upon
who or what was actually measuring it
and light light takes this idea
to the extreme
[Music]
what would the universe look like if I
were riding on the end of a light beam
at the speed of light
[Music]
in the middle of the 17th century only
Roma was baffled working at the Paris
Observatory Roma was peering at IO one
of the bright moons of Jupiter like
clockwork of the Moon orbited the giant
planet in just over 42 hours Vanishing
from view as it dugged in and out of
Jupiter's Shadow except there seemed to
be something odd about this Cosmic clock
Roma noticed that the timing of io's
eclipses drifted he realized that the
timing of the eclipse of IO was somehow
tied to the Earth's orbit changing from
earlier to later and back again when the
Earth was either closest to or further
from Jupiter and it was then Roma
realized the culprit was the light and
in particular it speed he reasoned that
the drift in io's eclipses must be due
to a finite speed of light as the Earth
moved in its orbit the distance to
Jupiter changed and the change in time
was because light had to Traverse these
differing distances his initial estimate
for the speed was fast very fast 220
000 kilometers every second and
eventually more accurate measurements
tied the speed of light to almost 300
000 kilometers per second
but just what was this speed relative to
it had been the belief for centuries
that there existed a medium The Ether
that carried light waves surely
therefore light speed was relative to
this medium from Plato to Newton this
ether had long been suggested as a
solution to various questions in physics
but never firmly detected experiments in
search of evidence having failed time
and time again and so it was that in
1905 during his miracle year Einstein
rang the final death now for this
invisible medium
special relativity
the truth was that it was the speed of
light that was the universal absolute
and invariant measured to be the same
value for all observers across the
cosmos A lot has been written about
special relativity and although much of
it seems confused and paradoxical there
is a simple Central message at its heart
particles with mass such as electrons
chart out their own time as they travel
through space-time
imagine two clocks sitting at the same
location synced to show exactly the same
time
now take these clocks on two separate
Journeys speeding them up and slowing
them down in Newton's view of the
universe of absolute time if you were to
bring these clocks together again and
compare their faces they would have
remained synchronized but this is not
the case in Einstein's the relative
motion of the two clocks would have
influenced their relative passage of
time and as they trace out their
different paths through space-time when
they reunite their times will now be out
of sync
this mind-bending aspect of Relativity
seems too strange to be true but
numerous experiments have shown this to
be the way the universe works from
globetrotting atomic clocks to
high-speed particles and accelerators
time is definitively relative
but what does this mean for light light
had taken a central place in Einstein's
New Vision of the cosmos everyone in
space-time should measure the speed of
light to be precisely the same value but
in demanding this something else had to
give and so space and time themselves
had to bend become flexible and rubbery
to accommodate the consistency of the
speed of light indeed one immediate
consequence of Einstein's insights was
that light would feel the existence of
gravity and as it traveled through the
universe light's path would be deflected
by the presence of mass Newton's claim
of two centuries prior reborn indeed
experiments have worn this out again and
again with the results becoming more and
more accurate massive objects such as
stars and galaxies can even behave as
gravitational lenses magnifying distant
galaxies from the very early universe
and revealing the presence of dark
matter
the beauty of these natural telescopes
is clearest in deep space images
such as the first revealed by the James
Webb Space Telescope
and so the flexible nature of space and
time had truly seen the end of Newton's
view of a rigid universe
but again
what about
light
what did this mean for light's
experience of space and time traveling
at the fastest speed possible in the
universe the effects of Relativity
become extreme
very extreme all distances shrink to
zero as does the time taken to cover
these zero distances
and so for photons no matter how far
they travel across the universe
not a single instant of time
we'll take by even though this light may
have existed in time and space for many
years or light years even though it
would have been clearly formed by one
electron in one location and vanished
when absorbed by another electron in
another location the space-time distance
between these two events would be
exactly zero
Photon it is born and dies at precisely
the same moment we began this story by
following a lone Photon from its
creation just after the beginning of
time to its ultimate destruction in the
detector of a telescope orbiting our
planet today
and yet the photon itself saw nothing of
this not the intense light of Stellar
birth the catastrophic explosions that
come with Stellar death or the formation
of planets and eventual Rise Of Life on
our own pale blue dots
the photon
noticed nothing
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign